se espera que el presidente chino xi
jinping use el encuentro virtual con su
contraparte de estadounidense joe biden
para advertirle que debe dar un paso
atrás en el espinoso asunto de taiwan al
menos así lo señala el editorial de este
lunes del oficialista 'china daily'
según el cual beijing está resuelto a
realizar la reunificación nacional en un
futuro previsible sin importar el costo
las tensiones con taiwán están en su
peor momento en décadas en octubre xi
jinping mientras intervenía en un evento
para conmemorar los 110 años del fin de
la última dinastía imperial
intensificó su retórica de una sola
china y
la reunificación puede lograrse y se va
a lograr jeannie longo si la declaración
se hizo apenas tres días después de que
washington emitiera una advertencia
instamos encarecidamente a beijing a que
cese la presión y coerción militar
diplomática y económica sobre taiwán
entretanto otra fuente de tensión para
beijing es el pacto de seguridad entre
eeuu reino y australia más conocido como
abacus que en los próximos años
proporcionará a camberra submarinos de
propulsión nuclear cambiando la dinámica
de asia-pacífico esto a medida que china
continúa su acumulación nuclear
recientemente probó un sistema de armas
supersónicas
otros problemas incluyen la democracia
en hong kong el tratamiento de la
minoría uigur que washington califica de
genocidio y tensiones comerciales
xi jingping lo ha denominado como una
guerra fría entre las dos superpotencias